yeah i'm kevin i used to work at
razorfish then went to set my own coming
up call granddad Nabil to hear that
you're winning all the business from the
major agencies do you think it's because
there's a shortage shortage of knowledge
within around social media still within
the agencies I think there's an audacity
in the agencies right now that there's
not enough dollars there for them to
worry about it and they're gonna get
caught cuz that's when you know right
you know way morning I'm just learning
you being at razorfish you know like
because my fees are so much less than
one especially digital agencies it's so
funny digital agencies have been
shocking to me I didn't realize how
razorfish being one of them back in the
day the pioneer in a lot of ways I
didn't realize how digital agencies made
their money they made money by building
[ __ ] brands didn't need that really
expensive prices when I heard one of my
brands paid four hundred thousand
dollars for a web experience when I know
how much it cost for square to build
[ __ ] Foursquare not some dumb [ __ ]
landing page I [ __ ] my pants it blew my
[ __ ] mind I'm like I literally
thought they were joking to me I liked
it like the fun like and like
everybody's like I was like oh yeah i
was literally stunned i was like wow
like it was probably the moment when I
realized oh I'm gonna kill these [ __ ]
and you know because because I was like
if they're ripping off brands like this
for that here's a digital agency at
least traditionally not everybody i'm
generalizing but it was the first 30 of
33 things I saw my brand spending money
on hey build this website pay us way
more money than you should especially
from a guy like me that knows how much
startups pay to build something and then
spend your money to drive awareness to
it Ludacris not the rapper